[Applause]
Khloe Kardashian has no plans to leave
Tristan Thompson this according to a
source you can turn your life around you
can go through hell and high water but
you can still come out and have a
beautiful positive happy life et has
learned the 33 year old reality star who
welcomed her first child with the NBA
Pro on April 12th is staying put in her
Cleveland home amid reports he allegedly
cheated on her multiple times while she
was pregnant
quote Chloe and Tristan are currently
very much still together and living
together and there is currently no plan
for that to change they're both there
for their daughter Chloe is madly in
love with Tristan he's her world but
some friends and family feel betrayed by
Tristan and cannot trust him according
to the source Chloe's chosen to forgive
him and she expects everyone else to
move on - I think to be happy that comes
from within
on Monday Chloe took to Instagram to
reveal their daughter's name true
Thompson and ET source says the pair
chose the name before she was born mom
Kris Jenner took to social media to
explain the adorable name they've given
their new bundle of joy was Chloe's
great-grandfather's name and her
grandfather's middle name Chris gushed I
am so excited Chloe named her daughter
true hashtag family tradition
thrilled